we're gonna talk about stem-and-leaf
plots now to help you understand I have
some daughter rhythm okay so it's
deliberate that this is quite a big set
of data in fact there are six rows and
column so that makes six by nine fifty
four feet across sports so I can count
that's right right now we get these
visualizations they're really useful
when you have large amounts of data if
all you've got to say these five guys at
the top one two three four five it's
drug rap Mac you just look at the
numbers and it's easy to get any better
way to look at that it's like no it's a
bit overwhelming if I can visualize it
I can understand it better so here's the
first thing that we're all going to do
let's get this data let's get it in some
water it's completely random at the
moment you could put it just in like the
America water you could sort it okay but
to help you do that a bit quicker
I want you to notice what's the range of
the data what's the lowest score you can
see and what's the highest school I
wanted to sounds like it's the smallest
okay and that looks pretty good I don't
see 101 I don't see a hundred I don't
see my two digits and what's the biggest
one looks like 196 do we do we have
anything baby that looks pretty bad I
can't soup bean that we have Donna from
102 all the way up to 196
okay what we could do is sort of group
this we could group this so we could
have like all of the numbers from a
hundred to a hundred and nine yep
fine we can group we can have all the
numbers from 110 to a hundred and
nineteen group them all
and you're all the way down I'm gonna
have a hole punchers and a whole bunch
of different sets okay so that's what
I'd like you to start by doing I've got
some candies for you I'll finish this is
not but you can finish it off yourself
too let's group these scores in these
groups and then we'll be able to see
some patterns here look carefully we
didn't miss any I'll leave that on the
screen uses a lot of done there it takes
a long time you're starting to sense
then this is not the most efficient way
of doing this right sure there's got to
be a better way I do want to get these
in order and you know it would certainly
be harder to try and put them in
completely random order with no
categories but this is tiresome and take
a lot of space I mean if you notice what
I'm doing I'm going down the columns
right and then I'm just filling them in
the reason I'm doing that rather than
looking for all of these ones and then
all of these ones is that I want to miss
any right so if I know I'm going down
here
I'm not going to accidentally say what
we've got a score I'm just going to go
through in a in a methodical way it's a
lot gonna miss it
that makes sense but how could this
right look at this line in here in
particular right this is taking me
forever and it's wasting loads of space
I'm writing 140 140 900 I'm writing the
one in the 400 over never again and
every score in this category is gonna
start with a 1 in a 4 right sorry
he is a better way to do this being that
all of these scores have 1 in 4 in
common and all of these scores have 1 3
1 2 1 1 etc ok underneath where you
started doing this ok I'm going to ask
you to make another pot but it's going
to start off a little bit different we
can finish this one later but this one's
gonna be much better so
these are we going to do I want you to
do with your ruler if you go on if you
don't have one you get one leg up we're
gonna rule a couple of lines to make
what we call a stem and leaf plot you'll
see why it's called a simile plug in a
minute
become what one's going like sir hey
so this stem and leaf plot is made of
two parts unsurprisingly stem and belief
okay so we've got a stem over here and
what I'm gonna get is a bunch of leaves
over here and I'll explain what those
are in a second thank you so remember
here my categories right one zero zero
one zero one was with it etc these all
start with 1 0 these all start with 1 1
or star 1 2 etc so the stem is how your
numbers begin so I'm gonna call this 1 0
1 1 1 2 1 3 you get the idea
okay you may be so far
so here are going to be all the numbers
that start with 1 0 now you notice I've
already got some numbers here ok 200 205
so all I write is and just now I'm going
to put these all the same distance apart
I'm gonna write the 2 and then the 5
going to put them right next to each
other but two of the five they symbolize
a hundred and a hundred and five okay
yes questions no I'm gonna put them
right together okay and you'll see it
like this right here I'm gonna have 110
110 111 I'm gonna have a few more scores
got this way 120 328 consi 828 etc
what's this next one gonna be here it's
just the 333 I've got a whole bunch
sheet okay now he's only gonna do two
things number we're gonna complete this
all together secondly I want you to note
right see how I'm pretty just the
numbers I'm just jamming and right
together okay that's because I know that
each one of these is what I call a leaf
it's its own number this is not like 388
for instance okay I set up this so that
I know that's 123 and 128 and another
128 okay so that's how I'm greedy you'll
notice up evenly lined up my numbers
right these numbers all and these
numbers all in up and you'll see why
once we finish this but that's really
important okay so you've got this set up
I'm gonna finish it and you can finish
it at work as well let's create this
stimuli I'm almost done I'm almost done
let's say two things number one this is
not in order
yes okay look for example here I have a
whole bunch of words and they're
completely jumbled up okay so I could
take this list of numbers
this is manageable I could put that in
order and that would change the
stem-and-leaf plot into an audience that
means
but here's the really really cool thing
that you can do with stimuli spotted why
they're useful okay and this is why by
the way I had a piece of paper and I'm
just doing this on the whiteboard you
can do this in the books because you can
move your board I have got this plot and
I'm gonna take it and I'm gonna move it
and when you move it sorry lost my blue
tack and put it sideways so all the
stems are on the bottom lo and behold
what have you made
I've made a dot plot but it's got all
the information on it right this is like
the best of both worlds
I've got my I can see the clusters and
the outliers and so on I can see it okay
there's my mode obviously but if I want
to I can turn it back and I can actually
see what the numerical values are okay
does that make sense
this is why these